hi YouTube I'm Carl Ganter from circle
of blue at the World Economic Forum in
Davos and we're trying to answer the one
question that one priority well I give
you two one is to raise awareness and
develop the will to respond to the
global fresh water crisis now we have a
very complicated crisis with so many
different intersection points from
finances the climate to general
watershed management to biodiversity but
how do we respond how do we unify
everyone we understand that we have the
solutions we have many many different
options we have great challenges and
what I'm told here and elsewhere is it
the missing piece the really piece of
this puzzle is building the will and
building the awareness to respond so i
think if we can do that we can help
solve one of the greatest challenges
that faces us on earth